alright guys bangbang super-excited have
mark here thanks so much for for doing
this man
really glad to be here thanks for for
asking on yeah for sure let's start with
just your background like where'd you
grow up and what you do kind of before
you got into technology uh yeah so well
I grew up in New Hampshire so kind of in
the woods my dad was a software engineer
so we had you know TRS ATS and Apple
twos and things like that in the house
so I was super cool so became a software
engineer when I got out of school worked
in the defense business for a little
while and decided that was not for me
didn't like working in a leg room you
know not in the entrepreneurial world so
then I went to Delphi internet for a
little bit that was kind of a cool thing
that got me out to LA and I had an
office right next door to Sean Connery
and I showed him the internet for the
very first time which is a pretty was a
pretty funny story and then and I
started my first company a thing called
the palace which was this avatar virtual
chat in like 96 so very early and I was
funded by Softbank Time Warner and Intel
and it was pretty big you had about 10
million users at its peak which for
those days was just enormous right so so
yeah so that ended up there was the
business model the right weed nobody
knew how to make money off of these
things we now know the answer would have
been NF T's right inside of a virtual
world book we didn't have that back then
and we didn't even have payment rails
like there's no paypal the credit card
processor we just had no way to do that
stuff so so great phenomenal but not
really a business but did sell it so
that was cool and then did my second
company which was a thing called super
cig which was putting all kinds of
functionality into email signatures and
that you know we raised like two and a
half million for like Ron Conway and
some of those folks up in Silicon Valley
I'm in LA so up north and that was our
that was my crash company so so
unfortunately that one didn't work out
and then a friend of mine came to me and
said well I have a cup of it's sort of
on the ropes you're you're completely on
the ropes
why don't you come work for me for a
little bit and so I said yes my friend
was Travis kalmyk and later CEO and
founder of uber he was working on his
second company at the time a thing
called red swoosh so I did that with him
for about a year year and a half
something like that it was like maybe
four to six of us in a little kind of
cramped office in Westwood for about a
year and a half so he ended up selling
that company but like eight years later
hey stuff and and and it didn't really
did not look like it was gonna go
anywhere for a very long time so the
story the story that I've heard about
red swoosh is he basically everyone had
left moved on and do other things and he
just was persistent as hell and then out
of nowhere a bunch of investors started
getting checks and they were like what
the hell is this from and he was like oh
yeah I sold the company yeah it was kind
of like that and you know he I ran into
him I talked to him again and sometime
around 2014-2015 and I was very
interested in what was up with Hooper
obviously but but I was really more
interested I was like how the hell did
you sell that company right and and it
really was just a story of grit I mean
that's absolutely true that's that is
Travis so I give him that the real story
that I've heard is that Akamai acquired
another company that was in sort of an
adjacent space and they got a patent
portfolio with that company red swoosh
had a patent that threatened that patent
portfolio so out of an abundance of
caution they acquired a red swoosh as
well not for its business because there
were no engineers there were no
engineers there was no product there
were no customers that's why I was like
this is just this is crazy and so you
know it was he had something to
negotiate with and it was the patent so
it wasn't just sort of nothing but he
was able to negotiate a much larger exit
than probably another mere mortal would
have been able to do right because that
is Travis that's awesome and then what
did you do after a resolution yes so
after red swoosh I started another
stupid enough to start another company
and this one was a business social
network so yes we were a competitor to
LinkedIn and we started in 2002 I we
didn't know about LinkedIn yet because I
hadn't been publicly and
failed themselves there about six months
ahead of us so not terribly far we sold
we ended up we couldn't raise money for
it so we ended up getting to about a
million users when LinkedIn had two
million so you know we were within
shooting distance and then IAC Barry
Diller interactive Corp we beta they
basically acquired us their long long
sorted story but they ended up acquiring
us in 2000 2004 and and then you know we
didn't know how we made money it was
another one of these things it was a
great phenomenon but nobody knew how to
make money off social networks in those
days and it could have been a lot of
things right now we know what the answer
is but looking forward from these
moments those answers aren't clear it
could be you charge people to post right
or it could be you just it's free but
you give us your email address or
allowed to email market to you there
were a lot of people doing things like
that back then
so Diller came to us and said the great
I've acquired you I love what you're
doing it's awesome but all of my
companies are either number one or
number two in their category so you have
to pick a category of revenue and become
number one or number two in that
category within a year so I said alright
so I I kind of I kind of went away for
about a month to try to figure this out
and I ended up working with I hired
Charlene Lee who is now pretty well
known as an analyst so I worked with
Charlene a lot on sort of these ideas
and I came back and I said look it's
jobs it's all this is it's monster just
inside of a social network and you use
your social graph as a way to find
better candidates or better jobs that
you have connections to again this was
not obvious sort of it is looking back
it wasn't from that moment looking
forward so we went presented it to
Diller and this was before LinkedIn
decided to do the exact same thing so we
present to Diller Diller says you know
this is you know I like he said
basically look it's he agreed that it
was monster calm but monster spent a
hundred million dollars a year on
advertising so he was like I would have
to spend a hundred million a year on
advertising and we were like no look at
the growth we had the growth curve we
did have you know the the the the story
you know curve going up and
right and and we said things like
geometric growth we didn't have the word
viral growth if that wasn't in the
lexicon and it wasn't really sort of
commonly understood
so we're describing viral growth to him
but we don't have the words yet and he
just thinks were full of [ __ ] he thinks
this is just some [ __ ] we've cooked up
if there's nothing to his credit though
there's nothing in his experience that
maps to a phenomenon like this right he
comes from a world where you spend money
and advertising and then people come
right and so he wasn't wrong he just
didn't have anything to sort of relate
to it so he he basically said I don't
believe this
he said well come up with something else
and I said there is nothing else this is
the right answer and then there's all
the wrong answers and so basically he
was like well I'll buy you guys are your
contract said and that was that was kind
of that so I left and then I wasn't
really sure what I was going to do oh I
wrote and I started writing novels I did
that and I podcast some of the novels
one of the first people to podcast to a
audiobook I was one of three so we all
all of us ended up getting like millions
of downloads because we were the only
free audiobook novels in the world at
the time and then iTunes added
podcasting supports all of a sudden we
were the only game in town right so
that's a whole nother so yeah that was
that was this book this book here which
ended up getting published by
HarperCollins so that was a whole nother
little adventure I went on and then so I
was thinking about doing another tech
company I didn't really have a good idea
as piddling around with a couple things
and I got a call from Jason Calacanis
and he basically said hey I got a you
know I got a term sheet from Sequoia to
do this new wave search engine called
Mahalo and I'm looking for a CTO you
know what are you doing
yeah I seem like a good idea at the time
so I signed up and really it was a good
idea the time we were basically saying
humans were curating search results at
the time Google search results looked
very sort of robot II and and and there
wasn't really much meat there so you
know how today there's like that little
side card that comes down that shows you
kind of a summary of whatever it was
you're just search for that wasn't there
yet mahalo was doing that and except we
were trying to you know human curate it
on a much larger scale so we were right
the searches could be vastly improved
with some
human intervention but the problem was
is that you know we too in order to
compete we would have had to compete
successfully with Google to do that we
would have had to have a a corpus of
data that was competitive with Google
and and it took so long to make search
results by hand that after a year we had
like 5% of the internet done right or 5%
of all search results and so so
basically the end result was 95% of the
time Mahalo sucks 5% of the time it was
600 percent better right but that just
didn't really work in the end so so we
did you know we worked on that for about
four I worked on that for about four
years
Elon Musk was an investor so got to meet
him got to hang out with him and you
know Sequoia was an investor so some
there are some great people hanging
around in the Mahalo offices it was kind
of like Warhol's loft for a little while
so a lot of a lot of really interesting
and great people and ideas kind of
flowed through that office in at least
in LA it was kind of a center of action
for about four years and then I was I
you know long story short is then Jason
and I started talking and kevin pollak
started hanging around a lot the
comedian and Kevin yeah he's great I
love Kevin and and so you know Jason
knew from my podcasting days that I was
very into podcasting knew that that
world and so he said look let's do a
podcast and company will call it this
weekend and you can be CEO and we'll all
be three-way partners on it so we
started that and I did that for about a
year and a half and long story short is
we just couldn't make it profitable it
was just there was there was too much
diversity in the shows they were all
over the map so that meant we had to
sell ads against we had 30 shows and we
really had 30 different markets so we
could gain those sales efficiencies they
all have very different demographics and
some of the shows are too broad like
this week in music for example you know
one week it was speed metal the next
week it's classic rock next you know
next week is rap
those are completely different audiences
so it could never sort of find its
groove the tech shows did very well so
Jason show this week in startups that
did awesome we had I there was one I
hosted called this week in cloud
computing
we had Lincoln this weekend iPad we were
sort of following a lot of them with a
lot of a lot of the model that little
poor kid lay down right so tech shows
work the other shows kind of didn't so
we were sort of left in his no-man's
land so after about a year and a half
Jason said you know I think I can make a
run at it so he took he took a crack
again and he couldn't make it work
either but I left and then I again was
sort of like I'm not sure what I'm gonna
do so I consulted for a little bit I
just went to local VCS I said sword for
hire you know what do you what do you
need what do you need help with so I did
that for I was like a run in for about
two years and then and then I had the
idea for Guardian circle which is the
current thing that I'm doing right now
so anything else in the past you want to
talk about well so here's my question is
you have worked on many companies that
people who pay attention technology
especially over the last 20 years or so
well-known a number of those companies
number of those players that ran
companies founded companies what's your
biggest lesson learned through all of
that right whether it comes from the
people the companies like what would you
say is the biggest lesson you learned
through that whole time line yeah there
actually is a biggest lesson Todd Lee
and I learned it when I was at Mahalo
and Mike Moritz who is you know fabled
Sequoia partner founder came to visit us
one day and he he had like a QA asked me
anything session and I asked him the
question I said look you you you have
like 30 years there's either 30 or 40
years of venture capital experience at
the time you've seen a lot of stuff
what's the difference between the
companies that make it and become big
things like Apple and Google and the
companies that just died and I really
thought the answer was going to be
something like yeah well it depends
there's a lot of things a lot of factors
and and he said oh that's easy
the the the companies that focus on one
thing and one thing only and are the
best in the world at one thing have a
shot at being the Apple or the Google I
can't I can't tell you that for sure
they will but they are at least they at
least not have a lottery ticket and a
lot of times they do win the companies
that definitely fail every time are the
ones that can't take a direction right
they're like like Oh
oh there's money over an enterprise so
let's let's forget our consumer then go
over here right there they sort of get
distracted by all these siren songs
around them and those are the companies
that die and and if you're you know
pivoting like you know so so much you're
doing pirouettes like you're definitely
gonna die and that's the pattern that
he's seen so that's that sort of a B I
would this is not a direct lesson of
mine but when I heard this it rang very
true this guy named Bill Bill Gross who
found an ID lab and he has 30 years
worth of data from that where he
analyzed the so they did a study where
they analyzed what is the difference
between the companies that make it and
the companies that don't he did his own
sort of you know qualitative
quantitative study is it the team is it
the amount of money is it the quality of
the idea you know what's what where's
the magic and he and the answer was very
surprising and very clear the answer was
timing almost nothing else matters the
biggest coefficient of a company's
success is timing and there was
absolutely no question about this so
that was a pretty surprising but very
clear finding yeah it's really
interesting to how when you talk to
these folks who've been around for
decades right and they've seen
everything come through the door they
can boil it down to one thing right it's
not just oh it is this complex answer
it's like neuro like here is the thing
from my experience that matters the most
and what that really tells you is it's
like they've got the clarity of thought
and they really do understand it right
it's kind of the the adage of like if
you don't really understand something
unless you can explain it to a child
like they're able to boil it down to
here is the one thing that matters yeah
no I know and I have to say I I'm guilty
of you know look we're founders we fall
in love with our products right this is
a thing that I thought of I'm super
happy about it and when I'm telling you
about it I want to you know to me it's
[ __ ] Lord of the Rings right and I
want to I want to take the time to craft
the story but you don't give a [ __ ] you
have you have a million people coming to
you you just want you just let me get to
a point right away and and and also you
want the customer to get the point right
away because a customer's gonna listen
for like three seconds and you know
maybe do it maybe not so yeah
like I I'm definitely guilty of overly
prose you know overly talking my
products I think everyone is so let's
talk a little bit about Guardian circle
I was talking before we started that
like I feel like this is your guys Super
Bowl right so we we've got a high mimic
yes literally we've got a pandemic that
occurred that led to this economic shock
and now we've got social unrest in all
50 states and and even internationally
and so maybe just give us a kind of
overview of like what is guardian circle
and then we can kind of talk about like
why it's important given the timing
right now yes so Guardian circle is
friends and family 911 emergency
response so the idea is you download our
app and you get your friends family
neighbors also download it and then you
connect this Guardian system both you
have to opt in it's like being friends
on Facebook right and when you can not
guard the other at any moment you want
when you're in trouble you hit an alert
button so the idea is push a button help
comes so signal goes out to all your
Guardians their phones started exploding
with this evil klaxon sound which is
good because it's an alert this is an
emergency
and then when they when they answer that
alert everyone is brought into a shared
map and chatroom so in you know under 30
seconds everybody knows where everybody
else is and everybody can talk to
everybody else and this is the important
part this is true whether those people
knew each other beforehand or not they
all know you but they don't know each
other but getting your mom and your
neighbor talking during your emergency
difference between life and death
possibly right so so that's the basic
idea and so what are the scenarios in
which you guys kind of see it as being
most helpful is this like hey I'm drunk
and I'm lost or is this a thing where
I've gotten a really serious car
accident like how many understand kind
of but the situations where you guys
foresee this being used yeah so well I
can tell you the situation that inspired
it which which is a great example my
girlfriend had a stroke and she's fine I
like to say that right away so she was
but she works out of her garage she was
all alone
and she couldn't type and she couldn't
she was trying to dial the phone like
her brain just wasn't working right so
she could have pushed the button but
that was kind of it and I happened to
come home at a weird time and I found
her and brought her to hospital and it
all worked out but afterwards I started
thinking about this I'm like my god like
if I hadn't gotten there in time strokes
are like time dependent if too much time
passes you're paralyzed or dead so you
know and I realized and when I when I
reversed engineered the situation that
there was all kinds of help all around
her her neighbor was home several people
have been driving by you know in short
there were seven people within a
thousand yards of her during the course
of the emergency she was drowning in
help but she had no way to get to it so
and I was like well if somebody could
just push the button I started thinking
about guardian circle right somebody
pushed the button then you know and
somehow we could have an uber like
screen where instead of you know instead
of cars coming humans were alerted and
could coordinate then this would you
know your network is closest and can
help you fast this kind of thing right
so that was that was the original was
really about health things initially and
as we started showing it to people we
did show it does if there's a there's a
place called crypto blockchain plug here
in LA and it's sort of you know it's in
the inner city so a lot of folks there
are scared to call the cops they're like
we just look we don't call unless you
know somebody's arm is chopped off then
okay but other than that no they'd
rather sort of handle things themselves
so anyone that likes neighborhood watch
kinds of things for whatever reason it's
very appealing to them if you're in a
remote area where the cops can't get to
you it's also very right it's not really
a practical option called cops gonna be
here in an hour right that doesn't
really help you so and then finally
women's safety is a big concern that a
lot of people think of with this so we
you know the X PRIZE people when they
found out what we were doing they were
doing a woman's safety XPrize to protect
women in India and you know they're the
cops when the cops come the cops usually
assault the woman also so which is just
insane right but so the answer is not
more cops right so
you know in India they already know kind
of what America is now knowing for the
first time they've known it for a long
time that you can't rely totally on the
police so you know there's you know the
woman's safety a lot of jobs that women
are alone and possibly going to be
isolated by a creepy guy real-estate
agents
hotel housekeepers that's it's a big
problem for hotel housekeepers in fact
there are now panic button laws that are
coming out of nation wired requiring
hotels to buy products like you know
what guardian circle has we are now
selling into that market we're just
starting to sell into that market
ourselves so you know kind of a wide
range of things but you're right that
before all of this Cove 'add and other
things when we told people about
guardian circle our pitch was kind of
like 9/11 one's not good enough in a lot
of ways they don't know you know they
don't know your location when you call
from a mobile device there are problems
with 9-1-1 but but most people feel like
911 one is safe right there if you're in
America like yeah I'm good i just call
9-1-1 i'm fine and we had a hard time
kind of getting a lot of people to him
you know people don't like to think
about emergencies so getting on their
radar was just tough right unless they
already were someone that was at risk
elderly a woman who's been assaulted who
you know was just afraid of it happening
again if it was on your mind in some way
was easier but other than that it was
difficult over the last couple weeks
like three four yeah well cove it
obviously but the last week in
particular you know getting people to
think about emergencies is no longer a
marketing challenge right so that is
suddenly shifted the dynamic and now
people are seeking us out instead of us
seeking them out so yeah and it's the
thought process that it's something
there's kind of two camps right one is
like hey the kovat crisis has made me
think much more about those around me my
community all that kind of stuff but
then too is a lot of the social unrest
around police brutality and things like
that like I'm fascinated with the idea
of creating multiple layers when it
comes to community kind of protection
right so if you mission kind of
Neighborhood Watch is the the least
lethal easiest
kind of loosely organized group all the
way on up to we have a military that
protects the United States right and
there's a whole bunch of steps in there
what you guys have basically done is
used technology to create the equivalent
of really kind of a neighborhood watch
that's technology enabled and to me the
part that's really interesting is I
don't need to know the other people
right like I all we have to do is just
be connective if I know you and somebody
else knows you and you're in trouble
then all of a sudden were you know me
and that person are on the same team
right we're we're here to help you and
so putting us into some kind of chat is
a pretty interesting dynamic we almost
create these like ephemeral social
network graphs right around a person
yeah also the emergency world has a name
for it they call it dynamic we dynamic
group management or regrouping so but
yeah that means exactly what you just
said and that that is one of the key
problems to solve an emergency response
is getting all these people
communicating immediately that can clear
up the fog of war if you will around the
emergency and but they these people
don't have each other's phone numbers
they don't know each other's names they
typically have no way to communicate or
or anything that puts them into
communication so we found it we found
it's kind of a hard problem to explain
to someone but during your emergency
like oh [ __ ] I really wished x y&z to
talk to one another right now it's kind
of the top problem so so yeah that's a
big deal for sure and then I guess how
do you see the the acquisition
acquisition of users going here right so
like obviously before you had this whole
thing we had to convince people there's
a problem the headings of technology now
they're convinced like what do you see
kind of the change when it comes to the
acquisition and marketing yeah so I want
to touch on one thing you said earlier
because it just reminded me of something
I didn't say when we first started this
thing I thought of it as a CDN of help
right so just like Akamai they they have
peers at the edge of the network closest
to where the bits need to be delivered
and 90% of the time that's much more
efficient but that doesn't you know that
doesn't get rid of Amazon that doesn't
get rid of centralized servers it's
still need those the CDN is a boost is
like a booster rocket right and so in
the same way guardian circle was not
meant to replace the police
it's a CDN of help you know your network
as closest and can help you fast as like
a CDN but I never imagined that like
people would be like yeah you know I get
rid of the cops totally we'll just do
this and so I'm like you guys are going
further even then I would you know I I'm
still in CDN CDN of help world but you
know the the defund the police thing
yeah I think I think it's a moment I
don't think we'll end up truly with no
police forces around the country I don't
I don't think I don't think it's gonna
go there but I do think we'll end up
somewhere more in the middle so so we we
have we have changed our marketing you
know you've probably seen some of my
tweets where I've just been tweeting
things out like you know if they use get
crazier this could help it have to be
careful about how I say it to because I
don't want you know that there's a lot
of people we're trying to profit off of
this and yes we're trying to mark it
into it but we don't want to seem
ghoulish but the fact is we've worked
for four years on a product which is
perfect for this moment and can save
lives so you know yes we're going to
market it I think it's okay and I think
there's any moral qualms about doing
that but I do have to be respectful
about how I do it right so you know if
thinking through you know the tweet very
very carefully to make sure there's no
way it could be misinterpreted or or
taken the wrong way you know that's
changed I'm a bit more tiptoe away about
things so yeah and and on the defund the
police and demilitarized the police or
actually disband the police which is the
new one for me uh-huh
to me it's kind of this weird situation
where it would be hard to argue that the
police has not become militarized so the
idea of like hey maybe they shouldn't be
walking around with weapons of war okay
like I think some people you know that's
not that hard to get there when it comes
to things like defund which in New York
City there's talking about taking away
one of the six billion dollars in their
budget okay so you gotta make some hard
decisions that happens to every business
like got it where I think that you know
you're kind of hinting at and there's
gonna be hard leap for people is like
the disbanding of the police
right and when I said to somebody the
other day an actual thing I tweeted it
was look if you want to disband the
police
you better be like the biggest second
amendment fan in the world right because
it's like who are you going to call if
you can't defend yourself and you can't
call somebody to defend you either right
you get in this weird world so I think
well it's more like the either smaller
budgets or demilitarization is likely
where we end up
which gives opportunity I think for
things like this right that can kind of
provide more of the safety component
rather than the like hey there's
somebody who just robbed me is running
down the street with a gun like I don't
know if I'm calling my neighbor as much
as I'm calling the police right yeah
yeah so guard easy rule can provide a
much bigger buffer zone between you know
the guys with the guns and all these
problems in between that could be solved
by a lot of other people right so you
know and I think we'll have I think we
have a much bigger role I think where
this will end up is somewhere in the
middle and there will be a much bigger
role for things like Guardian circle and
you know a layer of Community Emergency
Response that doesn't fully replace the
police but you go through that first
before every okay is bad enough we'll
call the cops but I think if you get do
to your point if you get rid of the
police I often lay that just creates a
power vacuum and that will be filled by
mafias and Yanks like that's where that
will go because people you know then you
know this things gets crazier people
like some someone save us and that's
when the Mafia and the gangs be like
well well you know we'll save you but
you know cost you a little money right
you know that'll happen right that's
that's where it'll go
so look look ask any soldier if they
went to Iraq or Afghanistan they will
tell you that many people in those
communities not all of them but many
people in those communities will say hey
when the Taliban you know looked over
our village it sucked they were super
violent but there was law and order
right and all of a sudden when you guys
went and ran them out of here there's
now this power vacuum and yes we're
trying to replace it with democracy and
you know all this kind of stuff and so
that transition period is actually very
weird for those people right because
there used to kind of a very rigid kind
of oversight obviously when you come at
it from democratic ideals like we do we
say hey well you know look there's a
better path
right let us help you do that but but I
definitely agree that you know when you
have that power vacuum what happens is
people that you probably don't want
being in charge end up being in charge
right yeah that's rittle go so it's
unfortunate democracy is hard and law
and order is hard right now you know the
pendulum is really it's swung very far
in one direction right now so emotions
are high and while there's a huge
absolutely a point behind where the
emotions are right now we're not we're
not thinking about the the logical
consequences of where that thinking goes
yet
I don't think in fall so what do you
think is the biggest risk right cuz like
I always find it interesting when timing
lines receive product now in kind of a
more macro environment it's like BAM
okay everyone's paying attention right
now hey we're gonna roll this product
right into this great timing how do you
think about risk during this time so you
know send one on like the marketing
message and more kind of like people
misconstruing or seeing something as
insensitive what are the other risks
that you see yeah I mean for us I you
know it took us it really took us four
years to get to what I called you know
in my mind is the 1.0 version of the
product so in that that was it's really
a 3.1 version and that came out and kind
of the end of last year there's a lot of
reasons for that and a part of his money
so you know we we did we did do a token
sale so we do have a token called guard
and there's a wallet inside of the app
and you were earned tokens for referring
people into the network so the more you
help build the safety network the more
you earn so so for us you know the risk
had been getting to you know getting too
much publicity before we were ready now
we're ready now we're scalable
everything's good so like the timing
just weirdly worked out perfectly on all
of that but at the same time you know
Guardian circle is a free service it
doesn't make any money which is fine it
doesn't it doesn't cost a lot for us to
run it so it's not really it's not like
we work or uber where we're spending
gobs of cash it's not that but but it's
it's
you know we need a way we need to either
raise money or we need to have some
revenue coming in so the risk right now
is is is the microts risk right of you
know diverging our focus so we did have
some funding lined up in March which I
won't go to the details of that but
bottom line is is about it was about
five million and it fell through because
of kovat and the market you know any
time the market crashes venture
capitalist you know kind of their
limited partners like no we're we're not
going to give you our money after all
right so there was a fun closing and it
didn't happen in blah blah blah so so
then we said alright well we have to do
a revenue products and we looked at a
consumer revenue product and what we
discovered was it was probably too early
for that it was it was a great time to
grow the free product but where the
actual money is is in the hotel
housekeeping business so like I said
before there are panic button laws
coming into effect right now which
require hotels to provide housemaids
with panic button service and it's a law
in Vegas there's a California law that
looks like it's gonna pass and there's
you know a few places a few cities
around the United States but it does
look like the sort of thing that's going
to go nationwide in an aggregate you
know it's it's it's probably about a
billion dollar market in the u.s.
worldwide it's like five or six billion
something like that so so there's money
there and it's a it's a special case of
Guardian circle so we're building a new
product based on Guardian circle and
that efforts been underway for a couple
weeks now
it's almost done so that's a good news I
was actually afraid that this might be
you know a six month build or something
stupid like that you know there's some
modifications we have to make for the
product because you know if you're in a
hotel GPS doesn't work right you know
you can't really rely on GPS so you know
it's sort of a combination of Bluetooth
and NFC tags not at the NFC NFC tags so
some other technologies have to be
brought into play but the API that we
made for the devices for the XPrize that
API is now reusable in this context so a
lot of the sort of ladders that we put
down for ourselves we're climbing up
right now right
real light we didn't know when we were
putting those letters now why we how we
would use them but they've turned out to
be very useful now but the danger is is
that we you know we'll have a bifurcated
bite you know we'll have two focuses at
once you know about the hotel business
and the free products and you know if
we're sort of serving two masters that
will event which we are right now I'm
consciously knowing that we're doing it
but at a certain point that will become
dangerous for all the reasons Micron's
pointed out so right now that's my
biggest fear
yeah and how has it been kind of
navigating this while running a company
right so you mentioned kind of the
challenges with the fundraising side but
how I have other things around building
a product and managing a business kind
of changed due to the Cova crisis
well we become a crypto company kind of
around 2017 or so and we were already
working from home so nothing changed
there we've never had an office right
but I was I was basically living out of
hotels and planes for a good
year-and-a-half kind of you know you
know and and at kind of a crazy pace I
mean in my life you know there was there
was regular life for them there was
internet time you know regular time
later no time then then there was crypto
time right which was sort of even more
fast and more furious and and now
there's Cova time which is like another
crank and the crank in the ratchet and
but you know we were already working
from home but I'm no longer travelling
so that that has changed so I was I
actually think it played it played to
our strengths because the rest of the
world started acting like we already
were and I've heard this a lot we
already distributed to him we were
already at home so we didn't have to
reinvent ourselves whereas most of the
rest of the world did so the only the
only thing that did change is I stopped
traveling like a crazy man
so which is probably good so so yeah I
don't know no it makes sense and then I
guess also like as you guys continue to
build the technology how do you think
about kind of international market
versus the
domestic market and you mentioned kind
of India
you know endeavor but one of the things
I've become more and more interested in
is as people are forced to go inside due
to Co vid they send more time on the
internet and what you actually get is
you get a lot more kind of continuity in
the content people are consuming the
conversations that are having right like
you now let's say that you used to go
and have 10 conversations a day and
eight of those were in your local
community whether it was at a coffee
shop at the office whatever it was it
was non digital right and two of them
were digital and I'm making up kind of
percentages here right numbers yeah but
now of all of a sudden nine out of ten
conversations are done online
like the Geographic barriers don't don't
matter as much and so you actually end
up kind of colliding more and spending
more time talking to people and other
geographies whether they're domestic or
international and so how do you guys
think about marketing the product to
international markets versus
domestically and do you see a change
there based on this idea of like more
people are living in kind of the digital
economy than the analog one right now
yeah so there absolutely is a different
difference between marketing Guardian
circle internationally and domestically
internationally it's largely on Android
and you know making it making a product
for making an app for Android is just a
giant pain in the ass you're probably on
this bunch of times but you know again
all these different makes and models all
these different screen sizes all the
different handsets are running different
versions of Android you know you have
different carriers and it is just a
madhouse and so you know that was one of
the reasons why it took us so long you
know the product in shape because we
were dealing with all those problems and
and there's also different sensibilities
for what people will accept in terms of
permissions so we went through a lot of
different versions of the onboarding
process specifically because it
internationally a lot of people were not
getting their login code because SMS is
you know not that reliable outside the
United States so we had to you know put
things in like we
robo calls and other ways of getting
getting that information we even got it
enabled we haven't released this yet but
we did get it enabled on I always get
this wrong WeChat or the I can't
remember which whatever one of those is
the most popular one worldwide we're on
that so but and most of those people
don't like giving up giving access to
their contacts
however we used to have a version so
when you when you log in the Guardian
circle we ask for access to your
contacts so that we can help you invite
them to be guardians and we used to not
do this and we found that when we didn't
do it people just couldn't if we didn't
hold people by the hand and and do
everything for them that we could they'd
never ended up inviting people to be
guardians that was very difficult even
if you know they got into the system so
so we created an in-app contact manager
and an in-app invite system which is now
excruciating ly easy and wizard like and
it took us a long time to get there but
a lot of people internationally just
don't like that they're like nope I'm
afraid of this for one reason or another
however we've discovered that Americans
are not Americans are just like yeah I
don't care fine whatever great and they
are there the Americans are much I would
say healthier Guardian circle users all
of them have like you know least three
Guardians for the most part and even the
ones that don't have they have less than
that they've invited like five or six
people right so they the behavior is
that they are trying to regenerate you
know they're trying to generate more
users at all times and they're trying
out the alerts or doing practice alerts
so they get it and there are pockets of
the world that do get it but by large
has been more difficult to kind of get
it out to them so the latest version so
we just made a version of Guardian
circle because of the international
users which is now the mainstream
version where we we actually don't
require access to your contacts but you
can't send out invites to people you can
only receive them but once you are
guarded up with someone you can send
alerts to them they can send alerts to
you so the product is fully functional
except for the outbound invite portion
of it
so and and and to be clear also the
other thing the other big thing we ran
into was both domestically
internationally when we didn't do the
contact manager and sort of cleanse the
contacts there is a lot of bad data in
people's contact there's tons of it and
they just don't think about it so they
would send out invites to landlines and
then call us and be like it's not
working your product sucks and then we
you know we figure out oh you're sending
it's cool you're sending an SMS message
to a landline that's why right but
people just it's it's not in their
nature to sort of you have to do those
things for them so and that's true
that's that's unfortunately true of
Americans as well as people
internationally so yeah it's super
interesting to me too how you start the
year like the cohort analysis around you
know how valuable is a user that's got
three people who they've connected with
versus five versus one and
internationally verse domestically like
you can really kind of dig into this and
and part of this is when you have almost
these like micro social networks to some
degree really what you're doing is
you're trying to find who's the person
who's the most connected who also is
most bought into the mission right
because if they're bought in and they've
got a large network then they can kind
of pull a bunch of users with them and I
see a lot of companies who successfully
have done that and then others who they
knew that's what they needed to do they
just were unsuccessful in being able to
locate you know who's that person who
their social group will actually follow
yeah yeah I mean I think it was Guardian
start like start here for linkedin or
facebook or myspace or whatever in order
for it to be valuable never feel a lot
of people on it right so so you don't go
to it's like a nightclub right you don't
go do it unless a lot of other people
are there right so however in our
universe Guardian circle is 100% useful
if you have two to five Guardians it
doesn't matter how many people aren't
guardian circle you still have two to
five guardians you're not really
interacting with anyone else so in that
respect we're not really chasing the
people that have like millions of
followers like if we were Twitter or
Instagram or something like that but for
those people I mean one of the reasons
we did the guard referral program is to
give those people links so as they
recruit people you know three Guardians
with them youssef thing if they use your
link and get in the system you weren't
guard for doing it so you know that's
one way we're trying to engage with that
but other than that not really yeah
where um where can people go find more
about Guardian circle well we are at
Guardians circle calm and you know our
Twitter handles at Guardian circle so
we're pretty easy to find and we've been
pretty good about being very visible I
think so got it
and then I wrap up every episode with
the same two questions the first one is
super serious one which is what's the
most important book that you've ever
read oh I you know if we're talking
about business I'm a big fiction you
know I write novels so I was I love
fiction so there you know that's one
answer but I will get into that well
I'll get it to real quick so I love this
this series of books called The
Chronicles of Thomas covenant the
unbeliever and you know the plot is
basically Lord of the Rings except in
the 70s a guy from our world hits his
head and goes into this fantasy realm
and and he's like the Frodo right in his
book wedding ring is the ring so it's
it's very very well crafted and very
well done I've always loved those books
since I was a kid but in terms of
business I have to say crossing the
chasm it's an old one but still in my
mind the best one I also really like 0
to 1 by Peter Thiel that I also found
that was one of the best books I've ever
read and you know crossing the chasms
got one idea in it and it basically says
you know pick one thing and do it better
than everyone else in the world which
kind of lines up with what Moritz said
from Sequoia so it's a very hard lesson
to learn that is you know it's easy it's
easier to read and be like yeah I get
that and then you turn right around and
start not doing it right so it's it's
hard to put into practice so it's it's
one of these things where when you're
reminded you're like duh but it's easy
to lose track of it did it last question
is about aliens believer or non-believer
oh absolutely a believer no question why
just the the universe the universe is
just here it's here to generate life I
mean I feel like I and I I know it's
sort of a non scientific thing but it
just it feels to me that like there
would be no reason for the universe
unless what we're here to generate
and consciousness and so I have no proof
but it is my very very very strong gut
that life is just everywhere and this
idea we have about dead planets and you
know spinning around dead sons and
there's a lot of that and that's most of
what's going on I just my gut says no I
just don't buy it so aliens absolutely
yes I love it okay
this up okay what what what one question
do you have for me to finish this up oh
you know what I guess what is the most
interesting crypto project other than a
coin like a DAP that you have seen
lately like what's what's exciting you
right now is there anything or is it you
just kind of watch it I mean I am
notorious for yeah just Bitcoin look
we've made a bunch of investments of
different companies I won't play
favorites among among all of the
children if you will but by far I mean
Bitcoin is so you know head and
shoulders above everything else and and
really from a global importance
standpoint in my opinion right if this
ends up doing what we think it should do
in terms of assuming a certain role in
the world that'll be one of the greatest
technological innovations you know in
human history let alone in our lifetimes
and so I think that it's just really
really crazy that we get to live through
this yeah I agree a Bitcoin Bitcoin I
still say that it's more important than
the Internet and you know you look at
the Internet if the Internet software
gene in the world and it's mostly the
internet the Internet eight like you
know retail books movies
telecommunications and then that's kind
of it I mean it's not nothing it's a lot
but that's kind of it you know where's
Bitcoin you know maybe all the crypto
maybe Bitcoin but in some form crypto is
going to eat world law finance banking
reserve currencies right that meal is
just orders of magnitude orders and
orders of magnitude larger than what the
Internet
so yes I think it's more important than
the internet ultimately of it I love it
all right mark listen I preach take the
time to do this I think that people will
learn a lot here and we'll send them to
go check out a guardian circle but I
want to do it again in the future
really appreciate it Thanks thanks Bob